and nancy pelosi why don't you pull up
that video wolfe and nancy pelosi if you
guys haven't seen this by the way i
don't know if you guys have seen this or
not
uh if you haven't seen this to talk
about joe biden taking half the money of
all of uh
our buddy hunter yeah we'll get into
that next we'll get into that next by
the way if you're enjoying this
i know we did a couple things here we
last minute we posted this live so you
guys didn't know this was gonna be live
we could have done a better job
posting it earlier but we posted it
yesterday so many people are asking us
and pat
we love the podcast but we wanted to put
in our schedule and if it's not in a
schedule we're working we have certain
things going on
so i understand that part of it but
those of you guys that are the ones that
are still with us and you found the time
to be with us
put the thumbs up and share this if
you're enjoying it uh
and we'll keep it going if you haven't
sub to the channel either as well pl
please click on that too so this last
week pelosi goes on
cnn with wolf and they start doing an
interview and uh pelosi typically when
she goes on cnn and she's treated
royally nobody asks tough questions it
just doesn't happen
she looks very calm she looks very calm
like hey they're gonna give me nice
little questions and i'm just gonna
blame it on trump and they're gonna
agree with me and uh it's gonna be good
the american people are because all
these guys are democrats they don't want
trump so
i'm going to win here and then this is
what we're not going to watch the whole
thing
all it takes the first 30 seconds to see
what happens and it will go on how it
ends at the end
so kai if you want to press play who are
being evicted from their homes they
can't pay the rent
many americans are waiting in food lines
for the first time
in their lives can you look them in the
eye madam speaker and explain
why you don't want to accept the
president's latest stimulus offer
well because thank you very much wolf
and i
i hope you'll ask the same question of
the republicans about why they don't
really want to meet the needs of the
american people
but let me say to those people because
all of my colleagues
we represent these people uh i have over
30 years
over here no no go over here and what i
want you to do is i want you to go
every time he talks uh i know what keep
going and find the next time he talks
to them and their needs are not okay
right there
go back a little bit
but they really need the money right now
uh and even members of them
but even members of your own even
members of your own caucus madam speaker
uh want to accept this deal 1.8 trillion
dollars congressman rowe connor
for example let me just let me just
quote a man you know well
i assume you admire him he's a democrat
and he just said this he said people in
need can't wait
until february 1.8 trillion dollars
is significant and more than twice the
obama stimulus
make a deal put the ball in mcconnell
court so what do you say to roconna
what i say to you is i don't know why
you're always an apologist
and many of your colleagues apologize
for the republican position
when has cnn ever been known for being a
political next part of a problem
that the president refuses to address
but you know that is
that that is the corona virus we know
out there but there are millions of
americans who have lost their jobs
they can't pay the rent their kids need
the food that's right and that's what
we're trying to get
1.8 trillion dollars and the president
just tweeted
stimulus go big or go home he wants even
right now why not work on a deal with
him
and don't let the perfect as they say
here in washington be the enemy of the
good well i will not let the wrong be
the enemy of the right what's wrong with
1.8 trillion
you know what do you have any idea what
the difference is between the spending
that they have in their bill
and that we have in our bill do you
realize that they have come back and
said
all these things for child tax credits
and
earned income tax credits or helping
people who have lost their jobs
are eliminated in their bill do you
realize they pay no respect to the fact
that child
care is very important for people whose
children
cannot go to school because they're
doing remote learning
and yet they minimize the need for child
care click on the next one
president about this go back now
asking you obama and excuse me madam
speaker
i'm asking you serious questions because
so many people
are in desperate news right now let me
ask you this
when was the last time let me let me
respond
when was the last time you spoke with
the president about this
i don't speak the presidency
why not call him and say mr president
let's work out a deal it's not going to
be everything you want
not going to be everything i want but
there are so many americans right there
we're in desperate need let's make a
deal what makes me
amused if it weren't so sad is how you
all think
that you know more about the suffering
of the american people than those of us
who are elected by them
to represent them at that point uh it is
unfortunate that we do not have shared
values with this white house
and that they have in their bill why
don't you talk about in their bill
a tax break for the wealthiest families
in the country while they cut out the
earned income tax credit
for the poor active it will be
registered here's what you wrote in a
letter to house democrats madam speaker
and i asked him
only as you know so many millions of
americans are suffering from well you
know
two people who know nothing about the
agreement or
there is no agreement but what the
suggestions are as if there's some
authority she was talking about andrew
please give equal weight to 12 to all of
the chairman on the committee
who have written this but so many of
your fellow democrats in the house they
want a deal
right now the problem solvers they all
want a deal
right now and here's what they're
complaining about because you wrote a
letter to house democrats and you said
this let me read
a line from the letter uh you so we have
absorbed
nearly a half a trillion dollars more of
expenses
still within i understand all of that
and i have only the greatest respect
madam speaker i have only the greatest
response down one point
i just want to set up a trillion dollars
1.8
trillion dollars 1.8 trillion dollars is
a lot of money the american people need
that money asap
because they're suffering right now and
i'm i'm not saying it's perfect
but i'm saying you don't care how it's
spent i don't care of course
she does now but i don't know you don't
even know how why not why not
talk to the president everybody mr
president let's get a deal tomorrow look
let me say this the president has sent
mr mnuchin
to negotiate that's what we've done with
other presidents this isn't unusual
what president bush we had we did this
quite a bit because that's how you
negotiate to the last part
and then you should all trust it and
let's hope they get more treatments
let's hope they get a vaccine and madam
speaker i i
certainly respect you but i also respect
ro khanna i respect andrew yang i
respect members of the democrats
who are members of the problem solvers
they want a deal because so many people
right now well the problem solvers by
the way don't have any earned income tax
credit or towel tax credit in their
proposal either
but let's not go into it you evidently
do not respect
the chairman of the committees i respect
i respect them i wish you would respect
the knowledge
go to the end about me it's watching
millions of americans
who can't put food on the table who
can't pay the rent
[Music]
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good as they said he's nowhere near
perfect
madame speaker always the case but we're
not even close to the good
all right let's see what happens because
every day is critically critically
important that was happening i was very
uncomfortable to watch right so what are
your thoughts when you see that number
one and i don't care if you're left
right blue green whatever whatever you
have to respect wolf blitzer for what he
just did
yeah straight up i agree i tweeted i
gave him love i send the
sentence i know a lot of people oh cnn
doesn't do this he and andrews are that
that's a full-on journalist right there
yeah okay pressing the
uh leader of the house nancy pelosi do
you know what the democrats are doing at
this point where nancy pelosi is you
know what they're doing i'll use the
sports analogy
they're running out the clock they could
have sure
if they could have had a deal three
months ago four months ago
two months ago a month ago whatever you
want to call it they would have struck a
deal
now we are within almost two weeks of
the election
they are trying to give trump zero
w's in the last two weeks will amy coney
barrett be uh named to the court
i'm sure she will does she deserve it
most likely yes
that'll be a w for trump they're not
giving him the stimulus w i mean and
she's gonna take the brunt of it
she looks like an absolute fool yeah but
she's gonna play the fool for the next
two weeks you know she's got a
reputation of having a temper right that
she goes off behind closed doors you
could you could see that she's seething
she's really upset
first time i've watched cnn in a long
time and i thought that is good tv
that was good tv because there was
conflict yeah there's never conflict on
cnn it's
you know it's the same crap all the time
so i thought that was amazing wolf was
phenomenal you just never see pushback
like that ever and i've always liked
wolf and i always want to see that out
of him and you know that was textbook
performance there and then
my mind always goes different directions
when i watch things in the media
here was my initial reaction after i saw
this we're two to three weeks
away from the election the economy
and this stimulus package is a huge deal
it always is
when people vote if this 1.8 trillion
gets passed
there's a good chance trump gets
reelected i mean that is a victory lap
he can take
for one and a half weeks that's why the
democrats are stalling it my mind goes
to this
is it better business for cnn to have
their arch enemy donald trump as
president
and now in the final couple weeks
they're going to do some subtle small
things to maybe help him out you never
see that ever
ever that helped trump that interview on
cnn and my thought is
is cnn is relevant if their guy is in
the office for the next four years who
do they rail against
you know so i i literally think it's
better business for
msnbc for cnn to have
trump as president and they're gonna
you're gonna see more of this in the
final two and a half weeks
by the way just so everybody knows this
this is the most viewed video on cnn
maybe in the last couple months just so
you know this this is the most
viewed video got 3.1 million views in
two in two
in two days they don't get 3.1 million
views they got 3.1 million views in two
days the most viewed video they've had
in the last 60 days
crazy stuff to see something like that
take place with pelosi because american
people are sitting there saying
finally you're holding people
accountable you know that's one of the
things that i liked and missed about
john
john uh is it johnson johnson i just
like this style man because he called
republicans out he called the left out
he was just a guy that you knew he was
going to go out there and not just be
somebody saying oh yes you're perfect
the only person he acted perfect was
obama when the two got together it was
like perfection he can't do anything
wrong
outside of him he helped people
accountable
[Music]